breaking news we have the first prison
sentence coming from special prosecutor
Robert molars from Prussia investigation
the indict II is 33 year old dutch
lawyer alex vanderzwaan he lied about
his contacts with a top Trump campaign
official and a believed Russian spy he
was found guilty and he has been
sentenced to 30 days in prison and he
will also be paying a fine of $20,000 he
will then be deported back to I believe
he actually lives in Germany even though
he is originally Dutch not exactly
something that sounds like a super harsh
sentence but the truth is that if you
consider the normal sentence for just
telling a single lie to the to law
enforcement it's actually sort of
serious right thirty days for a sentence
that's considered for a crime that often
just gets probation is not nothing and
there are lots of people saying well but
hold on he got one month and there was
potentially a six month maximum sentence
that's a fair statement but most people
end up not serving any Janne say jail
time for just a single isolated lie to
authorities there's no money laundering
here there's no other crimes that would
sort of enhance that sentence but at the
same time when you hear a guy got 30
days while a woman on parole who
accidentally voted illegally is getting
five years you're understandably a bit
confused and and I really get that but
the real tragedy of the 30-day sentence
is that it's going to provide serious
ammunition for the committed make
America great again Trump is to say look
at this never-ending investigation
endless interviews millions of dollars
spent and 30 days of prison to a Dutch
lawyer this is a witch-hunt to whom I
would say I would just say listen we're
still in the early stages of this
investigation here and vanderzwaan is
connected to Russia in that he's the
son-in-law of a Russian oligarch who
owns alpha bank that's a bank that we've
talked about before and at the center of
a lot of I guess we would call them
coincidences although I tend not to
believe in those type
of coincidences and this is the fifth
guilty plea in Robert Muller's
investigation of Trump Russia first that
leads to a prison sentence so far and
the big indictments of course have been
Paul Manafort his business associate
Rick Gates Michael Flynn and Trump
policy adviser George papadopolis and
vanderzwaan was never a major player
he's not even really a major link he's
someone who incidentally lied to
investigators in the course of them
looking into the real potential
criminals and still he's ending up with
a felony on his record getting deported
when he gets out of jail and I believe
that you know I think I said Germany I
believe he actually lives in the UK he
is a dutch lawyer but he doesn't live in
the Netherlands I believe it's the UK
where he lives so sentence number one
make of it what you will my presumption
is this will not be the last sentence in
Robert Moeller's investigation the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad